Vsauce Kevin here teleport to Mars and
hop into your flying car maybe our
expectation that sci-fi technologies
would become reality like flying cars
and moon colonies came from the pace of
innovation leading up to the Cold War
space race if man can go from flying
across the Atlantic Ocean to landing on
the moon in only 50 years then surely by
2015 we'll all have flying cars well the
problem with flying cars is basically
everything current models are really
roadable aircraft because combining a
great plane and a great car create
something that's neither safety is also
an issue driving in two dimensions is
already dangerous with over 1.2 million
fatalities worldwide each year and cars
falling out of the sky would make
matters worse
realistically flying cars have to be
completely automated what we really need
is a scientific breakthrough that solves
taking off and landing from your
driveway without giant noisy propellers
or that keeps us from having to drive
car planes to the airport like somehow
manipulating quantum gravity which at
this point is theoretical teleportation
is actually possible it's just really
hard quantum teleportation allows us to
transmit the state of an atom or photon
over long distances with the current
record being a photon teleported over 88
miles the process works something like
this you have three photons with quantum
states a B and C B and C are entangled
and remain entangled whether they're in
the same room or one is on Mars you
basically measure the photons and use
that information to turn C into a and
effectively teleport the subatomic
particle state data of a not it's actual
physical matter to Mars
the problem with teleporting a human is
the amount of data were made up of a
calculation by the University of
Leicester puts us at approximately 2.6
times 10 to
forty-two bits and transferring that on
a bandwidth of 30 gigahertz would take
350,000 times longer than the universe
has existed also to teleport this way
you would have to die and then be
reconstructed which raises concerns
about the human soul spirit or
consciousness and whether that's all
just data that can be measured and
copied and you can't teleport to a place
humans have never been before you can
only teleport to a lab stocked with a
pile of atoms waiting there to
reconstruct you space colonies require a
massive amount of will and investment a
recent study suggests that a minimum of
10,000 people are needed to provide the
genetic diversity a self-sufficient
space colony requires a fleet of twenty
five ships holding three passengers each
with the roughly two-year round-trip
time would take 266 years to transport
10,000 people to Mars it would be a lot
easier to start by setting up a dome
colony on the moon sections of which get
almost eternal light for solar power and
greenhouses other parts of the Moon even
have access to large deposits of water
ice although it's so widely distributed
we need to develop a way to harvest it
but while there we learn everything from
para terraforming which is creating a
pressurized airtight roof to how lunar
gravity affects pregnancies we can take
that knowledge to Mars which may hold
the key to discovering extraterrestrial
microbial life this could show us a
different model for biology life on
Earth all has roughly the same chemical
makeup so comparing it to a new
biological system would greatly advance
our understanding of biotechnology and
medicine so the universe could be filled
with single planet species that have
gone extinct but we don't have to be one
of them and as always thanks for
watching
you